all right guys
bang bang i've got keith here uh thanks
so much for doing this man
thank you thank you i'm looking forward
to it absolutely
uh for those that don't know you let's
start with
uh where were you born where did you
grow up and how the hell did you end up
in
uh in media organizations sure
so uh i was born in new york city
as i was telling you where as you know
at this point
you know uh a bubble unto itself
um i i grew up on upper east side and uh
now live on the upper west side so you
know essentially gone very far in my
life
and i you know went to school upstate
new york
uh and i joined conde nast
out of college i interned at conde nest
and interned at wired
uh and then intuned at bars technica i
entered it wired and
ran wired uh ultimately uh
and then ran rs technica and then
uh went over to bloomberg media and
became
ultimately over time the global chief
revenue officer and then
joined time and i had a brief stint in
between but uh
you know mark and lynn benioff mark
being the ceo of salesforce
um and his wife bought time as a private
asset
and uh you know their vision for it was
that
you know it's a challenging time for
media and they
ultimately wanted to make sure that they
could preserve what they felt
was a you know rational centric
perspective on the world
for the next hundred years and how do
you modernize that and
preserve sort of the integrity and the
trust that it's had for the past 100
years
and so i've been at the brand now for
i want to say a year and a few months i
think when i you came
on board over you know to check out the
offices when was that that was
november of last year right uh
you know we just moved in to to our new
offices in times square
but i've been in the industry for you
know
uh close to 20 years now
so your background uh is not in
journalism you've always been on
uh kind of the the business side uh and
many people
are more familiar with the journalism
side just because that's what they
interact with they understand
you know generally that there's writers
and that content is what they're
consuming
help people understand how are these
organizations kind of structured from a
business perspective
and then as either the global chief um
you know officer of revenue
or as president of time kind of what
your day-to-day responsibilities are
sure so you know when
when i was introduced to conde nast you
know which is the publisher of
wired in the new yorker vanity fair
vogue
the first time i ever heard about it you
know i knew it too from the
editorial on the content side and when
somebody said you should check it out
my first reaction was that's a business
and uh
and and i couldn't believe it and um and
you know what i
learned very quickly was um there's a
few different ways in which
you know brands that produce content
actually can monetize themselves
they can do it episodically which is
either
marketing support right so a big
marketer comes in and says they want to
buy advertising of some sort that goes
you know alongside the content um they
could do it episodically
meaning e-commerce right so
um you know we sell a lot of items in
the time cover store
for instance um uh episodically is also
affiliate
marketing so like revenue that we could
derive from
selling products and then taking a rap
share off of that or
through you know annuity streams um
which are subscriptions
right and when you look at that um you
know like right now we have
uh an annuity stream with the print
subscription of time magazine but we
also have an annuity stream with time
for kids digitally and we'll have
another annuity stream
with time as we continue to evolve the
digital infrastructure
of the brand um that's really the two
big ways in which
a media company makes their revenue
[Music]
and so obviously uh there is
this seismic shift or transition going
on
most businesses um were
you know majority ad supported for many
many years
uh a little bit of uh subscription on
just the actual distribution of physical
publications talk a little bit about you
know over the last 20 years how you've
seen that shift
occur because i think most of the people
who listen to this uh they're going to
be well aware of kind of what i'll um
i'll steal from shopify this idea of
like arm the rebels
right so this is mostly the the creators
the smaller publications
they've got their own perspective on
this shift to digital but
you've been inside the machine and so
how do you think of
um kind of that shift for that
transition as has been underway
sure so god how old are you can i ask
that question is that a fair question
can i ask that i
feel like we're not a job interview
right this is this is a podcast how i
mean how old are you do you mind me
asking
32. okay so you're 32 um
that means you have to say how old you
are now i'm 40 right
and and but i'm like benjamin button so
i like age backwards i'm like a 90 year
old okay so i just want to be totally
clear with this
no but okay so so take this for instance
right um
you know many people that i would say
are over the age of 40
have a relationship when it comes to
media with the platform
right so they say print or television
or radio and they mean
a magazine their cable provider
or terrestrial radio most likely in
their car
uh under 40 and then plus or minus five
years
right um most people have a relationship
with the experience that they have
right so you say tv and
uh you actually just probably mean
viewing video on a screen
right like you don't have a relationship
with what the platform is
and instead what your relationship with
media is is it's viewing
and listening and sharing and touching
and reading right and ultimately
if it's in print great like it might be
and if it's digital um a video
great you don't really care but you
don't distinguish between
sort of um how you want to actually
get your content you just say i'm in the
mood to view right and and
and if that's the case what's happened
in terms of
sort of audiences is that the way in
which consumers have shifted towards
these experiences
is very different than the way that
media had historically
been set up and structured so it used to
be that
like um if you looked at conde nast for
instance where i started my career
they were so dominant in magazines right
physical magazines and there's moats in
physical magazines
right like there's barriers to entry as
it relates to printing and distribution
and securing of these paper costs but
what's fascinating about the digital
revolution
is um all of these sort of things that
created moats at one point
for industries are disrupted because the
tools are handed to
anyone right to create whatever they
want
and what happens in that scenario
is um like the consumer is now
confronted with
infinite choice right and infinite
choice
because anyone can create anything now
and interact with
with with any individual seems like it's
the most amazing thing on the planet
with the exception of it becomes
extraordinarily paralyzing
right and so then all of a sudden what
happens is in a world of infinite choice
the advantage comes to the content
creators that have established
trust with their consumers right so like
you for instance have a tremendous
amount of trust with your
your fan base like i saw that yesterday
when you tweeted out to them what should
we be talking about
right like every time you and i interact
on twitter i get
more sort of comments than in any other
interaction
that's trust with your fan base you are
a filter in which
sort of people believe sort of the
topics that you're going to talk about
um uh that people want to see it through
the lines of
in that environment time in this
instance acts as a filter the red border
of time
acts as a sort of curator of trust and
people know that if i
put the time logo on anything right
whether it's digital or physical
uh that they're gonna get a certain type
of experience and that's not just for
time it's for any brand and so i think
that what happens is that in a world
of infinite choice it actually is a very
paralyzing
it's like euphemism it seems so amazing
it's actually very paralyzing existence
and what has to happen is brands exist
to sort of curate and reduce and create
filters
and so in that world obviously uh time
is a great example where
um you are going to and have done a
great job
of uh getting ahead of this transition
to digital
right and we maybe we can talk a little
bit about some of the public numbers you
guys have released in terms of
how that is going financially um but
in doing so you're going to start doing
things you haven't done before and so
how do you think through the filter of
keeping trust right not not doing
anything to kind of put that in jeopardy
even though you're going to go do kind
of new things right so not necessarily
things that
are uh new to the user but new for time
as a as a business so so it's really
interesting to ask that question
and and i appreciate you know one of the
biggest challenges i think that
i face at time is
uh the evolution from time magazine to
time
right and the reason is is that
and it's not to dismiss the magazine the
magazine's a platform within the within
the overarching brand
but the reason is is that for 97 years
essentially the brand has been delivered
and experienced one way for many many
people
and what's interesting is it's actually
been neglected
for about 10 years um by you know
previous owners whether it was time inc
or meredith as you know the industry
shifted and changed right it wasn't sort
of invested in
on a business end but consumers still
flocked to the brand
and what i found was was when mark and
lynn purchased it and they gave us the
investment
to start to look at where we can develop
in the first year what i've really
focused on with the team
has been building infrastructure and
productizing existing areas where
we know things work well with our
audience so
uh to give you an idea um when you think
about
the overarching ecosystem of time
it reaches about a hundred million
people a month right
um time magazine only reaches 1.6
million people
time.com reaches close to
30 million people times social channels
reach over 60 million people twitter
alone 17.4 million followers facebook
13 and a half million followers and so a
lot of what we've been looking at has
been
how do we productize certain areas that
already existed but people didn't really
think about it because it wasn't getting
marketed to their attention so like a
good example is is
time for kids time for kids is an area
that's been around for 25 years but it's
only existed as a classroom product
and that classroom product was print
only and
when the pandemic occurred what we
looked at
was oh my god there are parents that are
going to be at home
and for the first time ever they're
going to have to homeschool their kids
and they need a
product that they can trust as it
relates to
age-appropriate sort of uh news curation
and so we digitized time for kids on
march 23rd
right we did not know what we were going
to get into and as of today
time for kids is a global product right
it went from u.s to global it's in a 185
countries and territories
all 50 states red and blue which i love
um it is uh been produced in english
which is historically been the only
language
spanish chinese and we're looking at
other languages we've produced
creativity shows and a camp
series and over 350 000
people have registered for it right
since march 23rd and what we did
was and the way that we really thought
about some of our evolution
during the pandemic which sped up every
plan
that we had for this evolution of this
but what we did was we said
what are the real areas that people are
suffering or need help in
like where can we really help people
with and we found
that it was parents and teachers
and children so we looked at time for
kids
it was mental health and wellness which
is why you saw the launch of time for
health
the way that we did it was um
executives who said how do i navigate
this moment in time
which is why we went to columbia
business school and partnered together
to create time for learning
and ultimately expanded time for
learning to
you know sean harper at the usc center
of race and equity
and zoom to do a thing on race in the
workplace
um and it's also why we partnered with
red ventures to launch next advisor
as it relates to personal finance right
and so like when you think about
all the launches that we've done in the
past you know 90 days to 100 days
that i alluded to in my note they were
all based on looking at
huge societal trends and then leaning
into that
and that was where we we looked at our
communications now along that way
we launched other things too and at
varying degrees of success like we saw
that when we did time for giving
it seemed great but people weren't
really into it
right so like it wasn't as if we batted
a hundred
but we really did put out a lot of
things in the areas that we thought
provided either value or utility to the
consumer
and um and then watched what the
response was and when people started to
really lean into it we leaned back into
it
so obviously um there's multiple
components or kind of sequential steps
that you take right so there's
hey we need a product uh let's look kind
of in our toolbox that we already have
or we can create something new
what exactly is it who are we going to
target
and then it's actually getting it out
from a distribution standpoint
many people who see this they say oh of
course time can do this right they've
got
tens of thou or tens of millions of
people who follow them on social media
they've got the time brand
like this is a walk in the park for them
obviously in past conversations with you
i know that that might not necessarily
be true
and so talk a little bit about how you
think of like
the product creation different from
the distribution and kind of how you
guys
um maybe go back and forth between the
two to ensure that you end up coming up
with
a successful product but also one that
reaches a lot of people and can become
profitable for you
sure so i mean i i was thinking a lot
about this
question especially talking to you on
this
podcast given i i think a lot of your
audience probably looks
at uh businesses through the lens of a
challenger
sort of lens is that a correct statement
right um
and and i think that um you know one of
the
advantages time has as a brand is is
it is a very well-known brand it's a
very famous brand like i i've yet to
come across somebody who doesn't know
the brand but
everyone always says time magazine right
um
and and slowly people are beginning to
see sort of
other things um other areas of the brand
come come to life i think that the way
that
we navigated q2 specifically
right and i think that that was an
important moment in time because it was
i think every brand no matter who you
were
was equal at that moment in time like
you saw your fate
and it was a very humbling humbling
sort of moment and and
at that moment like what i really wanted
to make sure
and i know my team really felt was was
important to do was be
scrappy as possible right so it wasn't
like we didn't launch time for kids
after
you know six months of market research
like we just felt in our gut that this
was the right thing to do
and it was like we weren't gonna miss
this opportunity and so
um you know we found a partner that was
willing to
uh with e-magazines who's willing to
distribute
quickly we promoted quickly and
you know if you remember the day that
time for kids
went digitized that if you look back at
your dms on twitter you and paulina i
sent you both
notes that was like can you please
promote this right like it was like
there was no
there was no budget that went into it
there was no
um grand scheme major deck that went
into it it was
you know a handful of us saying hey this
is this has to happen and it has to
happen now
right like we've run out of time um and
i like that i mean i
i you have to remember like you asked me
where i was
where i grew up like i'm a neurotic
jewish male you know who grew up in
new york city believing that the world
was always going to end like i was made
for this moment in time
right like
[Laughter]
but like i looked at it and and you know
we were very fortunate that we had great
owners
we have great owners that allow us to
think long
and as we started to see success in time
for kids
and as we start to see things pick up we
were able to take that success and say
to our owners
will you help will you invest in us in
this area
to allow us to continue to build upon
this and
that's how we started to get funds but
we really did it with our existing
budgets and everything just shifting
around and
you know there's a great quote um
you know i never thought i would say it
from this individual but but it's a
great quote
from mike tyson uh and i don't know if
you know what i'm going to say
because everyone has a plan until they
get punched in the mouth and it was
you know like we had these gigantic
plans set forth
and of how we were going to evolve the
time brand and
you know q2 came about and
it was like a huge wake-up call and it
was like what are we gonna focus on
and we had to really go straight down to
core
sort of roll up your sleeves
brute tactics and so everything was
launched on
minimum viable products everything was
uh scrappy there was no
incremental money thrown at anything
there was no testing
theories and we we succeeded on a few
things
which we're leaning into in the second
half of the year and beyond you know
time for health was a success time for
kids was a success
um you know some of the franchises the
time 100 franchise and the time 100
talks was a huge success for us
um our ability to think about how we
could take time
studios and apply it to network
television from a business perspective
is a huge success and then there are
other things that we did that just
failed and like and then we what you
have to just do is
you have to just say okay what are we
gonna stop doing and forget it
and like we tried it great move on and i
think part of
the uh the lesson here for people is
like having a brand can sure can help in
some cases but it doesn't absolve you of
all the challenges of building a
business right
now you know like at the end of the day
uh you know we we had huge successes for
all the successes that i could point to
with like time for kids or time for
health or others
like you look at some of the stuff that
we put out like
20 people signed up 100 people signed up
like
i mean these are real like it's black
and white like hey
didn't work right and so there's no
there's no magic that says uh
because we have this great brand that
storied
um uh what we touch all of a sudden is
successful
what it what the magic is about the
brand is that we have established trust
that people are willing to at least give
it a shot or look at it right and that's
where
you know we have to lean into and that's
sort of our advantage
in this moment in time yeah um
i think there's a lot of people who uh
are in the startup
kind of technology world and uh they
generally write off
the incumbents in any industry you know
media or
otherwise and they just say look they're
so out of tune they don't know what
all the new technology is they don't
know the new platforms things like that
uh i know for you uh that's not the case
and you spend a lot of time
uh paying attention to some of these
trends i wanna talk a little bit about
um kind of two of them which is one the
rise of the creator
so kind of these individual uh content
creators that are
um um kind of becoming more popular and
then two is the platforms really that
are
empowering them so whether that is the
you know shopify's on the e-commerce
side there's plenty in the content space
but just talk kind of from your vantage
point how you
evaluate you know these trends and then
kind of the pros and cons
um as you see it sure so if i can like
i'd love to step back and just
um at very early in my career i was very
extreme
in my viewpoint of things i always
thought it was either like black or
white
left or right and i realized like
things aren't that extreme and david
pogue back in
uh 2010 before he left the new york
times he wrote this piece
i thought it was the most brilliant
piece ever and it was called the title
of the pieces
you know what i learned covering ten
years of tech journalism and
what he said was essentially that things
don't necessarily
things are not as extreme as people
think it is like things don't
necessarily kill
everything like um when mtv came out and
video
was supposed to kill the radio star it
didn't right but things splinter right
instant coffee didn't kill real coffee
um
you know like uh and you look at this
and you know
at the end of the day you could give
sure a lot of counter sort of examples
of areas where things did kill things
right
color tv definitively killed black and
white tv
the camera in your phone definitively
killed point and shoot cameras but it
didn't kill dslrs
right like certain things evolve out
and so i think that the reason i bring
that up is is that there's
there is value to incumbent brains
regardless of who you are
if you're structured properly right most
incumbent brands
can't get out of their way because
they're so big
and they have such established systems
that they can't necessarily adjust to
what the reality of the system is
and so when you look at like my
background for instance right
and and you look at sort of what my
specialty is like i like building brands
and turning brands around
right and wired you know for what it's
worth
you know was originally primarily a
print business
and it's a technology brand and you know
we diversified it
into becoming more of a digital brand
you know than
than a print brand and we really built
it up from the 18th smallest brand that
condensed the fourth largest brand made
back
every dollar and was the first brand to
cross that chassis
of you know 50 or more revenue being
digital
and part of it to me was just educating
myself
on consumer behavior and expectation and
i think that the most
important book i ever read in my entire
life related to business theory was the
innovator's dilemma by clay christensen
right and you know to give you an idea
of what a loser i am
i read it on my honeymoon okay so so i
don't know what you read on your
honeymoon i know you went to mcdonald's
but like
but i read the innovator's dilemma on my
honeymoon and i came back and i said you
know what i know exactly how we're going
to navigate this to my partner howard
in the time they said i know it's up
here we're going to navigate this
uh moment we're just going to operate on
the simple question of is this a good
deal for us
and we're going to shift the way that
sellers are compensated so that way
they're not protecting a cpm but they're
working
in conjunction with what clients needs
were
and also um you know how they could work
within the marketplace with maximum
fluidity
in every place i've ever gone the first
thing that i've done is shifted
the comp structure of the sales team so
that way a dollar is a dollar
and most places won't do that because
they're historically built on
very high cpms on one platform let's say
print
and much lower cpms on platforms like
digital
and until you're willing to realize
that all of those cpm protections that
people play
on uh p l's is is bs
it's not real right it doesn't make a
difference and most incumbents
don't want to change the way in which
they're accounting and doing their
systems and
thinking that granularly about human
behavior
right and success because the second you
shift the way a seller goes into the
marketplace and represents your brand to
represent the interests of the
marketplace
then you get a better outcome than the
seller representing the interests of the
brand itself
and you could work with the biggest
issue at hand which is the innovator's
dilemma and with speed
um i say that all because
most incumbents don't think like that
but here's where the incumbent advantage
is
and this is where like i will get my
advantage like i'm a privately owned
company right and
i'm allowed to evolve
uh without ever spending any of my time
on the street trying to raise money
right so let's pretend for instance that
you're a small startup i would say at
least 50
of your time is on calls trying to raise
money
right and um i don't spend 50
of my time raising any money i spend 100
of my time thinking about how to make
time a better brand
and so that is discounted tremendously
because people can't see brands being
able to do stuff like that because
they think it and then there's also the
award of the new
like people just love the new um i bring
all this together because
it's not i'm not defending uh incumbents
in the slightest like i actually think
that there are huge disadvantages to
being incumbent
um but the idea that it's an either or
world is what i would dispute like i
think that it's a world that everything
sort of exists
together and incumbents evolve
some some die and
some up-and-comers emerge
and most up-and-comers die right and so
so like i think that people don't want
to ever look at the world in that view
because it's not as exciting
it's actually quite boring yeah what do
you think are the advantages
of um these creators and these platforms
that are the up and comers so most of
them will die
but some will thrive the ones that do
end up thriving
what are you um not jealous of in terms
of the advantages they have that you
might not
but but more so just uh you recognize
that
uh here is an area where they are um
better than us or have
a structural advantage that you don't
sure so i
in content creators you know like
at the end of the day the only thing
content creators businesses are based on
is
is monetizing trust right
and uh and ultimately trust
manifests itself in how much time is the
consumer going to
provide me in a given week or day or
month
um uh with the brand of of that
individual
um i i
you know i i've been an entrepreneur my
entire life that works within big
companies right like when i was in high
school i had
a computer consulting company like i
like
the idea of like controlling my own fate
destiny
and i think that what a lot of these
content creators all of a sudden
realizes
is is um unbridled by
a larger sort of mechanism they could be
more
of themselves and they could find an
audience where they
can be happy just sort of creating um
a sort of a brand that is based on them
now the challenge with that is you know
most
people are 50 successful based on
themselves and 50
successful based on the brands that they
go to so like
if i was faced with the same scenario
in q2 but i was at a brand and i'm just
gonna make up the brand
called like um uh you know like i just
you know i was just petting my dog
before i came in here so let's we'll
call like
uh dog lovers united or whatever right
nobody would care like that that i was
doing all of these
new innovations and so part of my brand
gives me permissions to try certain
things
easier and um and then
part of the reason that the brand is
successful is because of the individuals
that are there when you're a creator
you could try whatever you want you have
no sort of limitations
but only the people that understand the
brand or know you
uh will accept it and very few people
outside of that will give you a shot
you know until somebody else has
convinced them that they should give you
a shot and so
if you look at some of the brands out
there today that i really admire
right you name shopify or sub stack or
any of these others
you know they give individuals the tools
but they don't give people the
destinations or the distributions
right like they don't give people the
means to allow other people to identify
or explore them
and so uh i mean does that answer your
question or
i feel like yeah i'm solidly there i
apologize no
i think that's great and and i guess as
part of that um
you know there's an argument to be made
of um
kind of the unbundling of media
organizations
uh but there's also an argument to be
made that many
platforms are simply just rebundling all
over again right
it's kind of like you're almost
unbundling under the current brands and
then just rebundling under
new brands like maybe talk a little bit
about uh you know do you agree with that
do you not can i
i do actually i i mean i i really i
don't know
do you know rich greenfield oh yeah from
uh was it
light street or late street partnership
like so so you know like i do believe
you know
like in his theory of the unbundling
right
and then ironically i also believe that
the problem with the unbundling is
it comes down to again this this
paradox of choice right and you
you unbundle and bundle and bundle and
then the consumer has infinite choice
and ultimately the consumer just says
god i just want to be i just want it
easy
right and so like that's why the
rebundling occurs
and i do think that what happens in the
unbundling is is
the the crap gets dismissed right it
gets
sort of pushed aside and i do think that
one of the things that's really
um uh lovely with the digital evolution
is um you're gonna start to see sort of
more efficient
things coming together right now the
problem
is you lose surprise and delight
right like so in a world where there's
no data
people made gut decisions like everyone
sort of
had some common truths around them and
and there was surprise and delight you
didn't know what was on the next channel
you didn't know what you were going to
read on the next page you didn't know
what was going to be
put together and like the editor's jobs
were to curate like a selection of
ideas for you and some of them landed
and some of them you didn't agree with
now where everything can be so
personalized what you actually get is
this custom tailored information that
almost puts you in your own little
unique filter bubble
and it divides people further
from having any sort of common truths
yeah
and is it a world where as this happens
uh the monetization right so we think of
it as like there's the incumbent models
which we talked a little bit about
but in these new models uh there's
completely different monetization
strategies
or is it a world where there's just only
so many right i mean it's basically
there's ad supported and there's
subscriptions supported and
either you're gonna do one of those two
things and maybe you can sell some
physical products right but
there's not like you can reinvent the
wheel over and over again on
monetization
so yes and no right um
there's a really interesting
uh i would say fallacy that happens
with transitions most of the time which
is as these transitions take place
most people think that the old manners
in which people consume
or pay for content or engage with the
brand
um can be applied to the new
technologies right so like
if you take you know the alexa
or you know your iphone when it first
came out or
any new device right most of the time
the
first sort of iterations of brains and
engagements on
these new platforms were repurposed
versions
of what people's experiences were on a
different platform does that make sense
and i think that what happens in that
world
is that people think that the business
models
that were applicable in one world are
also applicable in another world
and so they think about it through the
lens of
uh marketer support or subscriptions and
if you think about what i was saying in
the beginning is it's either
it does fall in the camp of either
episodic or
annuity right but it doesn't fall into
marketer support or subscriptions like
marketer support subscriptions
are sort of subsets of either episodic
which is what marketer support would be
and subscription would be an annuity and
here's like a real example
like look at television for instance
right
um like the traditional form of
television
um exists where the network would create
the content
it puts a huge investment in the content
creation
and then it sells commercials against
that
um the economics have gotten so unwieldy
that you're seeing it on like linear
television today
there's challenges right and you see it
you see
you know uh the shifts to streaming the
streaming wars are on what's happening
here
and that's very real right like uh i
i've never owned
a landline since graduating from college
i assume you don't have a landline with
paulina in your house right you just
have two cell phones
um and i'm willing to bet that my
six-year-old daughter doesn't have
a cable subscription when she
graduates from college and gets her
first apartment these are generational
ships
right where they where they go and so
the economics of television are going to
have to change
right and if you think about it like a
brand like time
has time studios which is its long-form
film distribution unit and historically
time
studios would create you know films for
netflix or
amazon and sell it to them the way that
we did with like a year in space
or we would work with magnolia and do
something like the john lewis
good trouble um you know documentary
but today we have the ability to create
content
for the networks take air time from the
networks
and split ad revenues with the networks
and that's a business model that never
existed before where it's like
all of a sudden you know i can look at
a television network and say i'm going
to take my brand and create content for
your network
so i'll fill an hour of your air time
i've now saved you
the content cost creation and in return
let's split
what the ad revenue would be let me own
the rights so that way i can
sell the rights internationally and it
can become a great new business and what
you're going to see
by the way and uh you know when does
this go live this podcast this afternoon
or does it go live like next week oh
perfect so on monday
so i'm telling this to you now before
but on monday we're going to announce
that you know we have
the time 100 this year being broadcast
on abc
on the 22nd of september at 10 pm
following dancing with the stars
right now that's a business model that a
year ago
could not exist but the pandemic opened
it up and so
i think that what people should always
do
as they look at any business or as they
will get evolving into businesses always
ask why
why can't we do this why are we doing
this
and if you can't get a rational answer
and if your answer is just because
that's how we've always done it then
that's the issue that most incumbents
have
as opposed to startups like you got to
get past
the cause who cares about because like
if you don't have a rational basis
like you got it you got to think about
how are you going to tweak it and fix it
yeah so i think when people hear that
right where you're going to take the
time 100 and you're going to uh
put it on television talk through a
little bit how you think about
uh a startup or an incumbent who
couldn't
you know have that conversation strike a
deal like that they would say oh if we
want to do something we're just going to
stream it on the internet
right so that's kind of one option the
second is on television and so
is it a uh attraction because of the
audience size
is it an attraction because of the
partner they're like why go to
television versus digital
i think it's a prime example of these
situations
so we do a lot of digital distribution
and we have a lot of success you know we
do the time under talks which we
launched in q2
not as a virtual event as a television
show we do it every week
and every week hundreds of thousands of
people actually tune in to watch it
and then ultimately it gets clipped and
it gets millions of views as we put it
through our ecosystem
the ability to get quickly into the
network world is
is uh i mean no matter how much it's
transitioning today
uh it's still gigantic right on every
level
and still where a lot of eyeballs are
today on every level
and so there is a prestige to being able
to do something of that
i think that what a lot of people tend
to say when they look at
sort of evolution is is um forget
forget targeting this person let's
target this audience like this is
useless
or this was the old let's go to the new
and i'm simply saying like
you can't discount anything like half of
the time 100 this year is going to be
digitized
right and it's going to be streamed over
our own site and over twitter and
through those feeds
and a portion of it is going to be
broadcast right
and i don't think like a brand like ours
should ever say either or like we should
play in all the different areas
um i learned quickly when i was at wired
a really interesting um uh
reality of getting talent
to to speak at events
and i remember
we had uh chris sacca at the
wired business conference god i want to
say
maybe in 2010 i might be wrong on the
year
but he made a comment to us to maya
drey's news now with me at times she's
amazing but she
he made a comment about about he didn't
he didn't come and speak to the wired
business conference for the 400 people
that were in the room
right like there were great 400 people
that we curated
he he spoke at the wired business
conference for the distribution that the
wired brand gave him
to the entire ecosystem that was outside
of the room
and i think that to any small brand
like what you want to think about is is
like there's one value to speaking to
your audience but if you don't have the
distribution to push it out
there's only so much influence and
impact that you can ultimately have
and um you know like i do think that
there's huge value you know we take the
time to talks and not only do we stream
it on our site but we stream it live
over
twitter and facebook and linkedin but
three very big communities for us so
that way we are maximizing what that
reaches digitally
speaking of digitally time is
already going through this transition uh
you have
drastically grown the digital revenue is
there a world where
it is 100 digital right and kind of you
do all the things that you do today
just bigger better there's more revenue
channels but
the legacy stuff uh kind of just erodes
away not because you guys wanted to but
just that the trends forced that to
happen
i i don't know i mean here i'll here's
what i would say
is um as it relates to marketing revenue
time is never going to be anything less
than a digital first
marketing revenue sort of organization
however
print um is still a very large consumer
revenue base for us
and you know what was interesting and
what we found was was
we had our internal projections as to
what we could do as it relates to print
revenue
and uh in q2 and we grew print revenue
six percent against
the projections that we had so like in
the most challenging quarter
we found that there still was a large
consumer demand for print
and you know what i would say is is this
think about horses for a second i bet
you you never thought you'd talk about
horses on this podcast
right but like back
prior to trains or cars
right like horses were mass
transportation right like if you think
about did you ever play the oregon trail
game
like growing up like how'd they get
across the country
horses right but then trains came around
and what happened to trains uh what
happened to the horses when trains came
around they became vocal transportation
right
and then cars came around and what
happened to the horses
they didn't go extinct they just came
relegated to two very specific niche
audiences
gamblers right
you didn't see that one coming and and
the afghans right collectors
and i think that print um is gonna fall
along that same spectrum like i don't
think in my lifetime or in your lifetime
uh print is gonna disappear but i do
think that
the value proposition that it provides
is going to get continuously
defined by the audience that it wants
and then all print
products are going to have to choose um
are you delivering
what the expectation is of that audience
and so like in the case of time if you
look at it like the value proposition of
time is
it sort of captures living history in
the moment
right like the magazine has gotten rid
of and shed
certain things that historically the um
the was uh that the internet is
essentially replaced
right and it goes to bigger thought
leader pieces it goes to bigger sort of
contextual pieces
the goal of print is to see the ongoing
conversation of the internet not to
compete with
it right and then ultimately like if you
look
and you'll see very subtle cues with it
like we're slowly like
we increase the paper stock right make
it a slightly better
product right like and you you
think about it from that perspective and
so i think again that
the people who think that like oh print
is dead
well yes in the marketing sense print is
seeing the floor drop
very quickly there's still business
there right but like
from the consumer fronts there's still a
very strong consumer business that's
existing
one of the last things i want to talk
about is uh
you focus on the business side of time
these legacy organizations have spent
literally decades uh figuring out the
right balance between
uh the business side and the editorial
side um and in many cases there are
you know very strict kind of firewalls
and can all the things that i think
people
would expect in the challenger case
though
uh for many creators they are the ceo
they are the head of editorial they are
the operations person the accountant
kind of everything um and so
without speaking to the editorial sites
i think that's kind of very
case-dependent
how would you if you're in their shoes
think about building a business right as
a challenger in terms of
where are the things to think about
where are the places to spend time how
do you think about kind of
you know you don't have a lot of
resources so you've got to kind of jump
start that just talk through a little
bit like if you're in that challenge or
see what would you think about
yeah so i think that um you know
ultimately i go back to this equation
that um if you're in the content
business
right like what you are ultimately
um monetizing from the business end is
trust
right and you don't actually need
a divide between between edit and
business
if the business side understands
the importance of that sort of um
uh mandate which is if you violate
trust and in this world where there's
cancer culture and where anything can
sort of
you can make a mistake and it can be
over very quickly
um if you violate trusts you're dead
right and in that sort of equation
[Music]
my advice is build trust with your
audience
and if you build trust with your
audience and accept
advertising revenue as part of your
streams
then the advertising that comes in
to your ecosystem just can't violate
that trust it doesn't mean that it has
to be bad advertising like as a matter
of fact
there was a uh an ad i once did i
i'll never forget this at wired for
netflix
that was um for one of their series
that outperformed every editorial piece
unwired
for the whole month and it was an ad
that we had built together that was a
custom continent
clearly stated advertisement probably 50
different ways
and the reason is is this in
an analog world
edit exists in one bucket and
advertising exists in another bucket
when it's
digitized it's only
sponsored advertising if it sucks
right otherwise it's just content
right to the consumer and so if you're
not if you're a marketer and you look at
some of the marketing messages that
some of the most sophisticated marketers
do like take a png in the world
right like they create amazing content
and then through that content they build
trust and the whole reason that they
want to be with a
content provider is because that content
provider has
trust already and their trust plus the
marketers trust
creates a really good association
altogether
to ultimately move product my only
advice would be
never ever ever ever ever violate trust
if you don't believe in the product
don't hock the product if you think the
product is amazing
then stand by the product um don't weave
the product into something unnecessarily
right like people could see stuff like
it's a stain on your shirt right if you
can see this thing
everyone can see the stain but if you
keep in mind the consumer first and you
keep in mind
the importance of building trust with
the consumer first that's all
then i would say that that's the basis
by which you should move forward
awesome i think uh that is the um
most important piece of this is it's not
the tactical right it's the the
philosophical here is
what you have to optimize for and that
can
inform a lot of decision making that
kind of goes off
yeah so wait before i leave i have a
question for you
all right you good well hold on yeah i
asked the same two questions to
everybody and then you get to ask me one
at the end
you get two i get one
you say you negotiate with paulina
no no no normally it's obviously two
okay
usually if she gets 12 i get zero okay
awesome okay so what are the two
questions i should know if i shouldn't
have prepped for this nowadays i have no
idea what these questions are gonna be
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
innovator's dilemma uh two books two
books that two best books i ever read um
innovator's dilemma as it relates to
understanding business models
as it relates to leadership the single
best book i ever read was a long walk to
freedom which was
the autobiography of nelson mandela
that's a great suggestion no one's ever
said that on here actually
can i can i give context for why i said
that of course
i read i read a book
um called a force for change by john
cotter
who's a harvard business school
professor who he wrote the book in 1988
and it's the difference between managers
and leaders
it's a really interesting book most
people don't distinguish between the two
and after i finished it i wrote him a
note and i said
i loved this book i think i was the
first person since 1988 that wrote him
this note right
and he wrote me a really nice note back
and i have lunch with him
and i asked him the same question that
you just asked me
uh about business books and leadership
and he said to me
uh i think every business book written
today is crap and i said why because
nobody researches anymore they just want
to turn it around in like three seconds
nobody does the hard work he goes you
want the best book on leadership
read a long walk to freedom and i said
juani because when nelson mandela
was released from prison everyone
thought that south africa was going to
fall apart
he goes i got book after book from think
tanks throughout the world from schools
from educational institutes saying
that south africa was going to go into
war and famine
and that there was going to be chaos and
that it was the end of south africa and
you know what happened
i said what there's none of it and i
look at him and he goes
you know why and i go why it was great
leadership
picture this you're in jail for 35 years
you get out and now you're in charge of
the people who put you in jail and you
don't actually
take you don't actually go after them i
mean it really teaches you about
the human psyche and how he evolved and
i just think that it's
if you're looking for a lesson on
leadership it's an amazing
amazing book that's a great explanation
second question
more fun question aliens believer or
non-believer
uh total believer why um i think
that you have to be so
selfish and self-centered to believe
that the universe is as big
as it possibly is and that they're that
we're the only possible living
entity now i don't believe that aliens
are green
figures with big eyes or whatever uh
but i can't possibly rationally believe
that in this entire universe and i don't
know if you've gone to the planetarium
at the natural history museum but it's
pretty big when they
when you go into it and you hear neil
degrasse tyson talk
i i can't envision that we're the only
living species now whether we're the
most advanced i don't know
but like i can't envision that we're the
only ones wait what's your answer to
that
oh yeah i'm with you it's just it's too
big the the three
key pieces and i've got the advantage of
i've asked hundreds of people this
question and thought about it way too
much is just
one uh are we more advanced or less
advanced
do we want to discover them or do are we
cool with them discovering us
right kind of the the conqueror uh or
the explorer usually ends up being the
more successful at least in human
history
um and then the third is just from a
time scale standpoint so there might be
other
life but is it you know a million years
before or after
uh you and i are sitting here talking so
so i have a great meme and i'll send it
to you after this
and it's a bunch of aliens talking and
it says year 2020 and the aliens go [ __ ]
we're up next
[Laughter]
that's awesome i uh uh speaking of memes
i don't know if you saw this i think it
was uh
maybe the new york times i can't
remember but somebody interviewed uh
elon musk
and uh the whole interview is you know
very serious right
and kind of everything from tell us your
vision for the you know future
to defend yourself the whole nine yards
and at some point
they asked him uh when your twitter
account was hacked
uh there was a rumor that potentially um
they took the dms of a couple of
accounts were you worried
and he said no not really like i'm sure
you could like take something out of
context and you know make me look bad or
something but for the most part it's
just me swapping memes with people
yeah right so it's like okay and then
like one of the follow-up questions was
if given the choice of being a
billionaire or a meme
lord which would you choose
and so of course the billionaire says a
meme lord right but
it's just like in what world do they
have elon musk and that was one of the
serious questions
right and of course he's like eyes light
up i'm sure and he's like
a meme lord what else would you want to
be
so so so my question for you would be
this
you know as we evolve time um
like we've really been rethinking a lot
of different areas
and you know you know this about me
because and i've said this to you
like i believe in this crypto trend like
i think it's very
real um historically
the only way in which you can get
subscriptions to time or
or whatnot would be um
uh through you know your credit card or
cash or check and you know we've slowly
evolved into different digital payment
methods through
apple pay obviously and others but if
you were to give me advice on how to
implement a crypto option on
uh subscribing uh to some aspect of time
like where should i start and how should
i think about this
so uh i will not say company name
because don't say a company
you you and i will both get eviscerated
online no matter which which name i say
um let's we're talking trend wise yeah
and
i think there's there's three things
right so one is um
if you stay within the traditional
confines that you have had in terms of
uh people are just paying for kind of a
holistic subscription whatever
that entails uh there's just the simple
uh
pay with bitcoin right so there are a
whole bunch of uh bitcoin payment
processors that uh
that can facilitate that and each one's
got you know pros and cons to it
and that's really people who i think are
uh in
crypto like bitcoin already have it they
just want to use that as their preferred
payment method
i actually don't know how popular of a
payment method that would be right
because most of the people
i think in bitcoin want to hold on to
their bitcoin rather than spend it
but that's one option the second is uh
there are a couple of uh payment
processors now that what they do
is um one that we've invested in even
that
says hey i'm going to take my dollars
and i'm going to pay
keith dollars uh but the transaction
is actually processed through the
bitcoin uh lightning network
so you get dollars i sent you dollars
but in between the
sender and receiver it is converted to
bitcoin sent across the lightning
network and then
converted back to dollars and sent to
you and the advantage is one you can do
it globally
you can do it much faster um there's uh
kind of a complete removal of all of the
credit card transaction fees
um and then there's no chargebacks right
so you kind of
from a merchant standpoint it's very
attractive
um and then you just get dollars you
don't have to worry about kind of the
the bitcoin component of it
so i think that's more realistic in the
sense of people
they just want to spend dollars right
and so they don't have to understand the
underlying infrastructure and the last
one is
i do think that there are or will be a
very big rise
in uh kind of these um digitized
currencies so
uh the digital dollar the digital yen
euro you know r b
whatever so it's the technology but it's
not
a change in uh kind of monetary policy
right so
what's there between a u.s dollar in
today's form versus a digital dollar
just the technology right and so yes
there's advantages to that
right whether it's cost or efficiency or
whatever um but but
really you're just moving dollars around
in a new
kind of frontier right love it
thank you so so the next time we chat
my hope is is that this is the topic
you're like how did it go
how did this implementation go and then
i will and i will credit you
and i thank you for that and thank you
for for having me on this today i hope i
was
uh remotely interesting to anyone uh
that was listening
well now that people know that you are
paying attention to your twitter account
uh when this comes out my guess is that
uh you're going to have a bunch of
people tweeting at you
either one recommendations for time or
two i'm sure there's a couple of
smartass challengers that will explain
you know why they're the next time
hoping that you pay attention
no listen any any any suggestions are
much much appreciated to your audience
and
thank you for for the kind words uh
yesterday i saw so many they brought my
ego up so high that when i read all the
nasty ones it brought it right back down
to where it was before you even tweeted
it out
so all right keith thank you so much for
uh for doing this i'll do it again in
the future
anytime have a great one